[Music]
david morrissey was a big fan of the
series the walking dead before starring
in it he loved every moment of working
on the show and found international fame
from it but he was never the same after
playing the governor here's why
when david morrissey was first cast as a
governor he turned to some of robert
kirkman's source material for
inspiration in an interview with sfx
magazine morrissey explained that he had
more questions about the governor's
backstory than the walking dead comics
seemed to address so robert kirkman told
him to read the spin-off novel the rise
of the governor for a deeper dive into
the character's history it wasn't until
well after that first reading that morsi
decided to jump into the comics when he
did he found a character who was very
quote dark and evil he decided that he
wanted to use his screen time to explore
how the governor transformed from the
character and the rise of the governor
to the epic antagonist seen in the pages
of the walking dead speaking with den of
geek morsi explained that while getting
ready for the show most of his
conversations about the governor were
with showrunner glenn mizera the two of
them talked about the governor's
psychology including his penchant for
manipulation and his comfort level with
the post-apocalyptic world around him
morsi wanted to create a deeply felt
three-dimensional character who would
shock fans of the walking dead comics as
much as viewers of the show
david morrissey spent some time studying
famous leaders in history to prepare for
the role he told the walking dead
universe that he read up on cult leaders
like david koresh and jim jones but it
wasn't enough just to absorb ideas from
cultists he also took a look at more
modern political leaders morsi explained
that the governor was able to offer
security to a whole group of people the
governor may be manipulative in that he
knows how to keep people in a state of
indebtedness to him but he also gives
people something they truly need
security morsi elaborated on the
governor's relationship to modern
political leaders in his interview with
denim geek he shared leaders have a
habit of turning up the gas on our sense
of insecurity as well as our sense of
security in order to manipulate us
despite that less than savory tactic in
the world of the zombie apocalypse the
governor can still be considered a great
leader because the security he creates
is real morsi said he doesn't distract
his populists with security you know
that's it security is everything
from the beginning david morrissey
wanted to represent the governor with
more depth than the character had in the
walking dead comics in the comics the
governor charges head-on into antagonist
territory he maims and murders without
much in the way of regret morsi's
governor is different his version of the
character understands the evil that he's
done and he struggles to square that
knowledge with his own self-image
speaking with sfx morsi has said the
challenge for him as an actor was making
sure that the governor did things for
his good reasons that they were
absolutely paramount for his character
that struggle comes to the forefront in
season four regarding the character's
appearances in that season morrissey
shared what the governor is trying to do
is run away from the thing inside
himself and he'll never run away that
struggle can be seen on the screen when
the governor kills martinez and shouts
the truth that he doesn't want the power
back
the governor didn't want to be forced
back into a leadership role because he
knew it would make him do bad things
again at the same time he felt obligated
to provide his group the protection that
martinez couldn't guarantee
the meat and potatoes of the walking
dead both on the page and on the screen
is the relationships between the
characters for the most part the
characters get to know each other at
exactly the same time that the audience
gets to know them in that regard the
governor is a very unique character in
the show because his relationship with
the audience is distinct from his
relationship to any other person in the
series david morrissey talked about his
relationship with entertainment weekly
he pointed out that the show's audience
gets to see the governor in ways the
other characters don't the audience sees
him at his lowest points and at his most
vulnerable moments no character in the
show has the same amount of knowledge
about the governor as the audience does
only the viewers understand the
character in his totality for morrissey
that's the best part about the role he
loved that the governor's relationship
with the audience is total
it's common knowledge that actors have
to get into the minds of their
characters and the process of
understanding the governor and his
actions made david morrissey more
empathetic in general morsi told sfx you
don't have to sympathize with him but i
have to empathize with him morsi needed
to understand on an emotional level what
would drive the governor to do some of
the things he does as with many other
people who do bad things morrissey said
he thinks the governor is driven by fear
what feeling could inspire more empathy
than fear for one's life at the same
time taking on the role forced morrissey
to look at the other characters in the
walking dead through a new set of eyes
he's openly expressed his love for the
show and its characters particularly the
main cast but that sense of love isn't
shared by the governor rick and the
others at the prison might be the
protagonists of the show but their
antagonist for the governor morsi
explained his view of the characters
through the governor's eyes by telling
den of geek they are a threat to his
security terrorists are a threat to our
way of life and that's how he sees them
in 2013 david morrissey spoke with conan
o'brien about the process of filming the
walking dead and how it ruined other
shows for him the series shoots in
georgia and they're often filming
through large portions of the summer the
heat and humidity is incredible plus the
actors are covered in dirt and fake
blood and many other scenes involve
intense action and athletic combat by
the end of filming a season many of the
actors have lost weight just from the
sweat and exertion horsey quickly
pointed out that the crew members and
zombie extras have it harder than he did
as they don't have air-conditioned
trailers to escape to in between takes
despite the heat everyone loves working
on the show and is incredibly passionate
about bringing the zombie apocalypse to
life on television however all this
changed the way he views one particular
series in the interview morrissey said
he used to be a huge fan of mad men now
he has a different perception of the
show he watches the actors wear nice
clean suits and play out their scenes in
fancy offices with air conditioning it
all leaves him wondering
how can you pick your checkup at the end
of the week
according to david morrissey no one
knows when their last episode of the
walking dead is going to be during his
interview with conan o'brien the actor
talked about the process the stars all
went through when they got a new script
for an episode they each took the script
back to their trailer to do a quick read
through to see whether or not they lived
through the episode usually the person
who stayed sitting in their trailer when
the actors regrouped was the one who
didn't make it
morrissey said the show's willingness to
kill off major characters was something
he appreciated about it back in 2013 den
of geek asked morrissey if he discussed
his character's eventual exit from the
walking dead with showrunner glenn
mizera morsi said i haven't actually
because i don't really want to have that
conversation despite that reluctance
morrissey knew his days were numbered
from the very beginning the governor
died in the comics two years before
morrissey's first season of the show
ever aired at a rhode island comic-con
panel in 2017 morsi told fans the cast
held a death dinner for someone whenever
it was their time to leave the show they
needed to have the dinners at someone's
house so the fans wouldn't see the group
out in public and start speculating
about who had died and unsurprisingly
there were a lot of tears behind the
scenes when it was the governor's time
to die
david morrissey had been acting on stage
and on the screen for years before
joining the cast of the walking dead
before the show though he wasn't
immediately recognized on the street
particularly in america describing his
san diego comic-con experience which
happened before his first appearance in
the series he told sfx we went down and
people went crazy for us screaming at us
as we were driving along outside the
hotel it was like being with a rock band
i'm a big fan so i'm in there driving
along like the roadie his roadie status
ended after the walking dead season 3
landed on amc the season premiere had
more viewers than any basic cable drama
in history the governor didn't make an
appearance until the third episode of
the season walk with me but enthusiasm
for the show hadn't died down at all by
the time morrissey walked onto the
screen over 10.5 million people were
watching him in the role afterwards when
morrissey attended comic conventions
with the walking dead cast fans were
screaming for him as much as for anyone
else
david morrissey had been a fan of the
walking dead before he signed on to the
show and he remained one after he left
though he probably still considers
himself a fan to this day he did
eventually stop keeping up with the show
on a weekly basis in 2020 morsi spoke
with digital spy about when he finally
decided to stop watching the show he
kept with it long enough to see negan
make his dramatic entrance it turns out
that morsi and jeffrey dean morgan are
friends and the two of them spoke about
the walking dead in the lead-up to
morgan joining the main cast morsi very
much enjoyed morgan's take on the
baddest of bad guys in the walking dead
but he didn't stick around to see how
the fight against negan played out he
said that his main reason for giving up
on the show was that with all his other
projects going on it was difficult for
him to commit to watching it in the way
the fans do however morsi stepped away
from the series at the same time as many
others the walking dead saw a
significant ratings dip in its 7th and
eighth seasons but is still one of the
most popular shows on television
could fans someday see david morrissey
back on screen as the governor he
certainly hopes so most fans got their
first taste of the governor in the
walking dead comics in the amc series
morrissey however fell in love with the
character through three of robert
kirkman's novels the rise of the
governor the road to woodbury and the
fall of the governor in an interview
with digital spy morsi said there's
stories to be told in those novels that
i think are really fascinating since two
of those three books all take place
before the governor's arrival on the
walking dead show there might be an
opening for a prequel spin-off in season
4 of the walking dead morsi had a
handful of episodes more or less to
himself as the show explored the
governor's fate after the fall of
woodbury he proved that he's more than
capable of being a leading man in those
few hours of television but when morsi
pictures coming back to the walking dead
he doesn't envision a prequel series at
all instead he says he'd love to return
to a film that tells the stories in
kirkman's novels rick grimes is getting
a movie why not the governor
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you